خلينا نروح على تركيا مشاهدينا اللي و
خلال جلسه في برلمانها لمناقشه ميزانيه
وزاره الاسره والخدمات الاجتماعيه والصحه
والداخليه للعام المقبل صار في فوضى عجيبه
كثير خلونا نشوف
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الفيديو الفيديو
كان سببه خطاب لوزير الداخليه لوجه كل من
الاعضاء حزب المعارضه ووصفهم بابناء
امريكي
صياح واوراق طايره وتصفير قبل ما يتطور
الموضوع اكثر بكثير خلينا نشوف
[تصفيق]
ابطال
احنا طبعا مش فاهمين شيء بس واضح انهم
زعلانين من بعض يعني عند الجزئيه اللي
شفتوها تحديدا والصراخ ورمي الورق على
الوزير البث الرسمي لجلسه البرلمان على
قناته انقطع لكن حاضرين صوروا وانتشر
الفيديو على فكره هذا تشابك جاي بعد اسبوع
تقريبا المشهد اخر مشابه جدا بس يمكن كان
اشد وطئه خلال الجلسه ايضا كانت بتناقش
الميزانيه اشتبك النواب وبالايدين
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
اشتباك بالايدي مثل ما شفته كان اعنف من
اشتباك اليوم اعنف لدرجه انه نائب حسين
اورس من حزب الخير
المعارض وبعد ما اخذ بوكس على راسه خلال
لقناه المستشفى مسكين ووضع في العنايه
المشدده وانقال انه عنده اضطراب في ضربات
القلب وضعه حارس الملفت انه بعد كل هذا تم
قبول الموازنات الحمد لله اللي كان الخلاف
هذا كله بسببها
[موسيقى]